let's have this conversation so when we
were on the podcast the other day we
were talking social economics and you
brought up a terminology that was like
oh boom my finance mind went on because
i'm familiar with the word market value
and the stock market and you know that's
my world and you brought up the sexual
market the sexual market value
so why don't you use the marketplace the
sexual marketplace like the stock market
this is the sector would you break down
what that is and the ladies can maybe
jump in
for i mean okay so when it comes to
sexual market value uh men and women are
different okay let's just put that one
out there we're not all the same we are
actually more different than we are
alike so we have different mating
strategies and as a result of those
mating strategies we evaluate the uh the
other person the opposite sex um based
on different criteria so for uh for
women it's uh
it's what we call hypergamy okay so it's
alpha seed and beta need or alpha flux
and beta bucks that's pretty much what
it boils
i
full disclosure this was a word i was
very not familiar with until very
recently and then i went down the rabbit
hole some of his videos included there's
a book that i was reading and he
actually gave me his book and it's i'm
like oh fascinated by it so please break
this down so okay um just a a very brief
rundown of what hypergamy is uh
hypercami is a term actually a
sociological term that was coined back
in the 50s for sociological studies of
the caste system in india and they
noticed that women of a lower caste
always tended to marry up into a higher
caste and that's where the origin of the
of the term comes from now we have
expanded upon that because women want a
like short-term benefits short-term
sexual reproductive benefits and then
long-term security benefits and so
that's why we say alpha seed and beta
need alpha flux beta books okay so again
i'm using those terms alpha and beta as
abstractions because i know somebody's
going to go crazy in the chat about that
probably a beta probably so yeah exactly
so when when we're looking at the beta
bucks side that's more the long-term
security side and we're looking at
parental investment provisioning and uh
protection is that what bucks is that
bucks yeah provisioning yeah resources
so long-term anything that benefits a
woman in the long term when it comes to
long-term security networking there you
go when you were saying that you you
value guys who have something that you
can actually
uh you know have a utility for that
would be uh i would term that as being
in the interest of long-term security
then there's the alpha seed side
i don't know
i feel like long-term you can't really
predict just because
like we're in the social media
era everything's happening so fast so
like even if you
think you have security like that job
might not exist anymore or if you're
dating down like someone who doesn't
have security he could create an app or
something so that's why like you make a
good bet
you have to make a good bet on a guy or
follow your heart yeah okay well the
problem with the problem with following
your heart right now is statistically
women don't follow their hearts they
look for they look for a guy who is
economically attractive and that is that
term has been around since you're not
saying attractive you're saying economic
economically well men are most men today
are economically unattractive let me get
your opinion on this in the ladies
because i before i even heard of
ipergami because i grew up in south
beach i mean we've known each other for
a handful of years i was in the bin of
the party scene there's models there's
guys there's rich guys you know the
whole thing and i remember this one time
i i came up with this question and now i
ask it all the time and i want to get
your guys thoughts on it would you
rather
be with i mean b relationship be with a
guy very wealthy you're taken care of i
mean you're you're driving what you want
to drive you're living where you want to
live you're shopping where you want to
shop
you're living your life
but he's kind of a little bit maybe
older a little sloppier not exactly in
good shape he's not ex you're not
exactly
attracted to him but you're attracted to
lifestyle that's option a option b
hot dude sexy ripped you know good sex
funny cool you know all that
broke as [ __ ] lives in his mom's
basement those are your two options the
basement got me though like i was i was
maybe sold on guy number two but the
basement
i'm just saying he lives oh my god
basement or whatever but that might be
really
but those are your options
wealthy
but busted
yeah you know broken hot who are you
picking queen victoria i feel like when
i first met you i probably would have
picked guy number one because i was
still experiencing those things um
but now
i would probably go with this guy two
you're twenty you would pick i'm 29 29.
well anyway you you you're saying that
you would pick i i knew him when i was
like 20 so i feel like yeah 21 21 for
the record 21 i promise you on the night
live right no but when you're like
you're 21 in south beach you're more
attracted to those
quote unquote glitz and glam and then
now you can kind of see through the
smoke and mirrors and like you're true
you wouldn't be truly happy so who would
you be with long term
the hot guy the hot guy but
like he ain't taking you i would give
him some business advice and he would
start some businesses together okay so
you're going to try to have him level up
because this is counterintuitive to the
hypergamous nature well she would she
would want to take eight she would want
to take a a chance on a guy with
potential so if the guy's hot and he
kind of has potential to actually make
some money later on then that's a better
bet than the guy who is
not that good looking but has a lot of
money and therefore it becomes sort of
this economic situation when it comes to
to the uh women marry a lifestyle they
don't marry a guy
i've definitely seen going on that i've
seen that a lot but um
i don't know i think like you have
choices so i wouldn't choose that
rebecca number one who would you choose
of that scenario the the the wealthy you
know not so good looking guy or the
uh broke hot dude and then what was your
counter argument uh what rollo had to
say who's your pick first
i just can't get into your choices you
have to
she states that you don't have to so
you're just going to stay single is what
you're saying you'd rather say which one
would you hope
would change
i don't hope anybody changes i think
that is a foolish thing do i do i've had
those offers yeah my god if i didn't
have some type of i have this
i have to work i have this mission i
have i have my work to do in the world
i've had that offer all the time of um
they're done with their money all they
want to do is enjoy their life so
there's no room for me to grow
i'm not into it i've had
many offers like what kind of offers
what do these offers look like
i thought you're gonna take out your
phone let me show you it's like let me
let me queue it up in my mind i've had
straight up marriage relationship we
don't have to get married you can have
your own place you can live here
uh there was one i've actually been
offered that as well yeah it's guys are
weird yeah they'll take care of you you
don't want to do it they'll buy me a
house next door the rest of like no like
the next generation with their wallet
totally then there was somebody else
he's like we would make beautiful babies
that's what he just seen like babies and
it's like he said you'd have you know if
you have access to this for like forever
no i just it's it's like manipulative no
i just do that just like we were talking
about the gifts it just doesn't do it
for me so i i hear these conversations
this is not my reality this is so not my
world and i know other people like that
but i mean just so so to your example no
i'm single
so you'd say i'm i'm i'm i'm no deal
yeah but how long are you gonna stay
single for that was the question meaning
until mr wright comes along and who's
perfect he's got the money independent
woman i got that
adam i don't need somebody who's got
money i i don't know if this escapes i
mean i'm a phd i'm an author i'm like oh
she says i don't know if this escaped
yeah i'm not
like i didn't show up off the street
okay looking for somebody to take care
of not asking at all but i know you
probably have very strong feelings on on
what she said she's career women where
do you stand on career women i mean
you're more focused on their career
statistic right now is what she is how
old are you
if i may never ask a woman there he is
okay well let's just say for sake of
argument you're in your early 30s okay
maybe a little older who knows
um
when women get to that age and they are
career women when they are strong
independent women
and have spent the better part of their
lives uh building themselves up to be
and have a doctorate um to um
to have their own business your pr
presume you have your own practice
um and our very your your personality
and your ego investments are built up
into what your achievements are and you
get to a certain stage that's not me
with the ego investments okay well you
get to a certain stage where it's like
i'm looking for a guy who is like why is
it do you think she's you're still
saying she wants to find someone that
she enjoys doing activities with and
things like that i haven't found the
right fit exactly and i'm not i'm not
trying are you looking for a guy that is
like are you looking for a guy that
makes as much money as you has the same
kind of achievement as you has the same
kind of education as you what this is a
great question what i've noticed i've
dated a lot and so i've tried many
different things
the
you can have somebody who's incredibly
wealthy and is awful at conversation
just like makes me want to kill myself
then there are other people have very
different things that they offer
so somebody who is maybe
not as well established maybe very
interesting then there are people who
have you know different kinds of jobs
right so i've tried i've tried dating a
lot of different people
what i find is i need the mind i really
need the mind the rest of it is sexual
no it's just
it just i need somebody who's i need
somebody who's incredibly smart
i just need that and i need somebody
also who is ambitious and really has in
goal like because there are very nice
people
and they're fine to work and this is
wonderful it works really well for other
people i am not looking to breed i'm not
looking to settle down i'm not looking
for any of that i have work to do in my
life so hold on stop you don't want to
have kids god no what do you mean god no
you don't want to have kids i never have
okay why is that
they're terrible kids are terrible
aaron clary this girl right here
i feel like do you want to have kids
i've always wanted to be a mother i
think it's my life purpose but um
like today's world
purpose is to have kids to be a mom okay
like i think
yeah like i always wanted to be a mom
and then um
would you rather be a mom or a career
woman
i think today you could do both i get it
i could also i could eat pizza and work
out i get it but like you got to pick
one though if i had to pick one then mom
yeah of course you'd be a mom but you
would have you've obviously picked your
career that would be my hell i mean like
i know i was so happy for you what
happened that that you were like that's
it
i'm never having kids she's like a
badass woman what do you mean clearly
she's a badass clearly she's beautiful
but
but you're very anti kids like like
usually like there's women
that will say look you know i'm open to
it if the right guy comes along yeah you
know but like you're very like steadfast
no hell no i got mission i got work to
do no kids first thing first when i get
to when somebody even wants to approach
me i was like i'm if you're looking for
a wife and children i'm not your guy you
have to be a girl
i want no part of this so like don't
don't come around so i've had people who
they'll date me for a while and then
they'll think they'll think that i think
they can change my mind oh my it's it's
really a waste of everyone's time i
actually like that you're like committed
though and know that i've had a couple
girlfriends that are similar and like no
they don't want kids
um
so like i actually really respect that
thank you how come you let me ask you
why are you single right now why do you
think you're single right now
because there's nobody i want to be with
right now
is that they're just not forthcoming or
are you just not me she's waiting for us
after valentine's day i see i mean i
meet men
all of the time
i know what i like and when it comes
around
what's the longest relationship you've
had
four years i usually like so
i have them like three years four years
two years like that see my my my read on
you is that you are the man you want to
date you you turn yourself into the guy
that you want to date and most women who
like are like sort of the boss babes or
the alpha females what happens is they
live these lives where they have to go i
mean we when you look at uh what college
college debt right now college
enrollment when you look at business
when you look at the fact that women are
complaining about guys not being
economically attractive right now and
when you look at that like i was quoting
these stats to uh to um patrick on on
the other show is you know men have to
make 58 percent more than the woman is
making to be economically attractive
also
from the women's perspective
um
you know guys
don't
i want to choose my words carefully but
from what i've seen guys don't want to
date a non-educated uh goalless woman so
we actually too have to like be our best
version to attract
the best partner for us okay so you're
the the way you're you're framing that
right now is you're looking in terms of
long-term security got like you were
just saying a little while ago it's like
you want to get with the hot guy right
you want like when you were 21 you had a
different set of criteria for dudes and
now at 28 20 29 years old you have
another set of criteria for them because
you're more interested in long-term
security from 28 to like 32 33 somewhere
around there as opposed to being 18 to
28 when the the priorities were were a
whole lot different and for for you yeah
um when you're looking at like say uh
yeah i know well
because you're looking at this from
hindsight right i want to hear i want to
hear my statistics right now okay so
what i was going to say is that most
women who are in your demographic let's
say um they can't find they their number
one complaint is we can't find a guy
who's who's got his [ __ ] together we
can't find a guy who's got a collagen
she has so many options i know you have
those but you're still yet you're still
single what is about those guys
that what is it if so you have all these
options
but you haven't decided it's delightful
why is the premise that i need to end up
with somebody
[Music]